sexualization is not actually
manifesting from this kind of
patriarchal pressure where men Force
women to beautify it's actually
manifesting as a result of a state of
the economy that has people want to
strive to do better to out-compete their
peers to keep up with the Joneses it's
linking beautification with status
seeking and not with the patriarchy
why do women take sexy selfies
ah we're starting at the big ones the
big questions
um so this has been something that's
been really fascinating for me for a
while partly because
um I'm a woman you know and I've been
through all of those teenage years and
my 20s where Beauty was was really
important to me
um and then I've kind of
passed that and whilst Beauty still is
important in your 30s as well
um you know you just see so many women
taking these selfies and and it seems to
be so so important to them
and um
one of the kind of strongest arguments
about this one of the most dominant
arguments about this is basically that
women really care about their appearance
they really care about beauty because of
the patriarchy you know capital P and
the idea there is that
gender oppression leads women to Value
their bodies more than they value their
other qualities
psychologists call that
self-objectification that's the kind of
techy term for it
um and
uh you know I think there is some truth
to that there's certainly a bunch of
people been talking about it for many
years but in my kind of opinion when I
first started looking at this topic of
research I thought that was doing a bit
of a disservice to women
um because from what I could see having
kind of been in that world and having
known many women in that world there was
something really Uber competitive about
women engaging in sexy selfies and and
beautifying their appearance as well
like it didn't seem to me to be
something that was done to women but
very much something that women were
owning and using quite strategically
um so
that's kind of the background of what
had me start to look at that question
and why I was so animated by it
um and we have found in a range of
different studies now
um that women take sexy selfies to to
seek status but this is a status seeking
thing you know they're interested in
gaining status in social hierarchies it
can be a very authentic and assertive
behavior
um and that saying they're only doing it
because they're pressed and the
patriarchy tells them they have to is
really kind of only showing a small part
of the picture of that kind of
motivation are you suggesting that uh
beautification and enhanced
attractiveness and displays of
attractiveness are one of the primary
methods through which women can gain
status
I wouldn't say it's a primary well would
I say it's a primary method let me think
about that
um
yeah I think I probably would actually
yeah it's definitely a big way and part
of that is
you know part of that just has to do
with our kind of cultural history where
for many women even to this day your
survival you're kind of flourishing
relies on you marrying well
um because you can't necessarily hold
much wealth for yourself so in that case
looking attractive really helps because
we know that men tend to prefer all else
being equal a more beautiful partner to
a less beautiful partner I mean I don't
think we need to get up in arms about
that it's a kind of a pretty logical
decision
um so partly I think the the importance
of seeking status through beauty comes
from that place but then there's
something else about it that's just
unrelated to that dynamic as well which
is humans have this tendency to think
highly of beautiful people you know more
attractive people they're more likely to
get hired they're more likely to get job
offers they have higher earning
potential in general at something like
10 to 15 higher wages
uh we think that they're smarter they're
not right but we think that they are
people have this bias we think they're
smarter we think they're generally good
we think they're competent
um and all of these kinds of stereotypes
and biases we hold means that investing
in your appearance can be quite a smart
move
why is it the case that for women sexy
selfies are a status seeking mechanism
if it's simply the case that this halo
effect pretty privilege goes across the
board and yet for men we don't see I
certainly don't see as many sexy selfies
from my guy mates as I do from my girl
mates yeah totally so there's a couple
of things about that the the evidence
that shows that we have these
attractiveness biases some of that
evidence is sex specific so some of it
is stronger for women right so you see
these effects manifest more for women
than you do men but not all of them
um
you know if you were going to do a
blanket statement I would probably say
maybe a third of them are stronger
amongst men and then the other
two-thirds there's no sex difference so
that you get the same effects for men as
well
um I think there's kind of two things to
say on why we see it more amongst women
one is we do have that context of women
needing you know of women having in the
past having to rely on beauty to get
ahead right so that's that but then the
other thing is
um
men can tend to have other ways of of
achieving status right and part of that
is historical and part of that is
um
that in most cultures and pretty much
all countries I mean the vast majority
of them men earn more than women do
earning is this really great way of
producing status
um and
if you look at what age sex is looking
for in a mate you find that
every sex is you know both men and both
women and you know people who don't
identify as either care about mates that
are kind people generally want mates
that are
um intelligent compassionate people but
as a blanket population level difference
men are more interested in mates that
are more attractive and women are more
interested in mates that have higher
status so men have these other ways of
of achieving status that aren't
necessarily as easy for women to achieve
I suppose if you were to compare the
number of car photos or watch photos
that guys upload online big animal
photos get about those you know hugging
a tiger yeah and that as well um what
are some of the things that you
discovered that can predict increases in
sexy self-feeing
yeah so uh uh one surprisingly is a uh
economic condition of economic
inequality so one of the things we did
was we so I run a big data uh platform
right I'm really I really love big data
I think it's fun and exciting and yada
yada so I run this platform and we have
um three billion geolocated tweets that
we designed this algorithm to geolocate
they span 10 years and we use it to try
and understand trajectories of of uh
attitudes and kind of cultural Trends
and one of the first things we did with
that was look at sexy selfies right so
buying by being able to take this kind
of big geolocated social media data and
we have data for every country in the
world and look at the prevalence of
something like sexy selfies across these
different countries and regions we can
then link that data to uh popular
population level data about that country
things like its degree of gender
inequality right its degree of income
inequality
um it's sex ratio which is you know the
ratio of men to women which is this
indicator of reproductive competition
you know
income education all these kinds of
things so we did this investigation and
we found that sexy selfies happen a lot
more in environments that are
economically unequal
we also looked at gender inequality and
we found that consistent with that
dominant argument we did find a gender
inequality effect meaning that sexy
selfies happened more in places that
were gender unequal just for the people
that don't know what does gender
inequality mean
that would be like how much more men
earn than women earn
um how many more
parliamentary seats men hold like a men
considered leaders in society more than
women and do they have more power right
um so you could kind of think of that
gender inequality metric as being an
indication of
um
the power of the patriarchy right High
gender inequality stronger patriarchal
power
and can and consent with that argument
we initially found this gender
inequality effect right but once you put
income inequality into that analysis the
gender inequality effect disappears
um and that may sound
a little like
a bit of kind of academic statistic
mumbo jumbo what's the real difference
it's all inequalities but it's actually
really important
um because what it's doing is saying
that sexualization is not actually in
these data at least manifesting from
this kind of patriarchal pressure where
men men Force women to beautify it's
actually manifesting as a result of a
state of the economy that has people
want to strive to do better to
out-compete their peers to keep up with
the Joneses right so it's it's linking
beautification with status seeking and
not with Patriot the patriarchy
wow okay why why do you think that
that's the case yes yeah so
um
I think that
in
evolutionary psychology in gender
psychology you know in Academia in
general we tend to underestimate the
importance of status seeking amongst
women
there is a uh
quite dominant discourse about why
status is important for men you know we
talked about a little of it like status
is important for men to seek mates
obviously status is important for money
money is important for everybody and
money is important for reproduction as
well so you know we tend to know that
men are interested in status but there's
been this disagreement and this kind of
uh
neglect of the importance of status for
women I think particularly there's
definitely an element of that whereby
any discussion of the more vicious sides
of femininity are kind of swept under
the rug that's not really something that
women do there is a a little bit of a
culture at the moment that masculinity
is not something that should be pushed
too much further forward which means the
subtext of that anything which is more
feminine should be something which
should be better yeah exactly and I
think that's one of the reasons why
um I mean I've had Joyce Bennington
Tanya Reynolds Candice uh uh Christina
Durante
um yeah a bunch of different people on
the show recently all of whom are saying
the same thing which is and for me
female intersexual competition is way
way more interesting than male
intersexual competition because it's so
much you guys are just like vicious and
cunning and nuanced and brutal it's
great but very nice on top of all of
that over the on the outside sexy
selfies as well so you know it's great
yeah yeah I I it fascinates me as well
you know and I
um I
think you know the the the
this idea that women aren't ferociously
competitive is just plain wrong we just
we compete in a different way than what
people have traditionally considered to
be competition status gives us different
benefits it doesn't mean it's not really
critically important though okay so
status amongst women is important yeah
economic inequality predict sexy
selfieing women are using beautification
as a tool to drag themselves out of a
situation in which there is increased
economic inequality let me bro signs
presumably because they can see where
they could get to because they're
exposed to the heights of good uh
economics but they are also exposed to
what happens if they slip a couple of
rungs down the ladder and that is a
motivation to say you do not want to go
down there you do want to go up there
what are the tools that I have at my
disposal I have a camera and a phone and
an Instagram account
allow the Selfies to occur yeah you
nailed it that's that's basically
exactly what we argue is happening now I
think there's a
wishes that affect of economic
inequality on wanting to seek status is
something that you see about both men
and women right so this is a popular
amongst everybody even rich people in
economically unequal environments get
more worried about status presumably
because they're worried about losing
status right so every economic
inequality makes everyone across the
board want to seek status but what
you're seeing amongst women and
particularly women for whom beauty is is
a form of capital right is that they
invest in that to try and get ahead
I think that um there's two kind of main
Pathways that could help them get ahead
one is the more obvious one if they
could use it to attract a high quality
mate right or and in this case that
would be a rich well-off man in this
economically ionic World
um but the other is all those other
biases and uh stereotypes that we
discussed about why Beauty benefits
people is that they could use it to
build social capital right people want
to be friends with beautiful people it
allows you to move in the right Social
Circles we know that moving in the right
Social Circles can have really important
ramifications it can help you build uh
networks it can and these can be same
sex and other sex networks
um it can also have you create Advocates
and protectors around you and and you
know none of these effects are going to
be Sledgehammer effects where all of a
sudden I put on lipstick and like 10
people are running to me going how can I
advocate for your interests Candace
um I mean this is not that strong right
so gotta remember that this is this is a
subtle kind of finding
um it doesn't mean it's not meaningful
though and it doesn't mean that uh it's
not strategic and Savvy to invest in
that yeah these one percent all the way
up I tell you what I'd love to look at
the I'd love to get David puts in to get
him to do his study about mail vocal
pitch and I wonder if men speak in a
lower vocal tone in areas of higher
economic inequality I bet they do yeah I
wonder if they do and amongst beautiful
women as well why do I feel like he may
have looked at that already I don't know
if he looked at the amongst beautiful
women thing but you'd expect that some
kind of environment that is increasing
make competition
could result in that kind of manner of
wild [__] happening he told me the story
about when he was at Uni before he'd
even started doing his big studies on
vocal pitch and stuff and apparently he
was stood in the queue at the
supermarket and he could hear these two
guys behind him and they were speaking
and he thought he was going to turn
around and find two jazz singers or two
sort of old guys that were smoking
cigars or something because their voices
were so low and he turned around to find
a pretty attractive girl in between him
and two guys that were in their 25s and
they're right it was a case that these
two guys were trying to Signal or audit
to release signal dominance to this girl
look at how big my vocal folds are look
at it
okay so that's how uh income inequality
impact sexy selfies but it also it has
to impact female intersexual competition
in other ways as well what else have you
learned
okay so we have looked at sexualization
and what else have we looked at
um cosmetic use
cosmetic use yeah we have so
um one of the things that we were keen
on in that study was not just showing
the effect online right because social
media
is its own world and and we assume that
what's happening online reflects what's
happening offline but it's always good
to kind of test that assumption so we
looked at
um women's purchasing of beauty products
as well amongst all the states in the US
where we had really good kind of data on
that and then we looked at uh beauty
salons and I think it was yeah it was
beauty salons and cosmetics so these two
other kind of indicators and we also
found that in cities in the US that were
more economically unequal in counties in
the U.S that were more economically
unequal that people were spending more
money in women's beauty salons and more
money on women's cosmetics and women's
beauty products so we kind of replicate
the effect there as well consistent with
physical appearance and Beauty becoming
really important in these areas and you
saw that beautification increased
assertiveness too
yeah so a lot of my work is on beauty
you know I uh uh it's been it's been a
kind of long it's been a long journey
for me partly I think this is because I
uh I I grew up in a family where my mum
had been a fashion model my dad had been
a fashion model and then my brother was
a fashion model right I was not a
fashion model had no resentment about it
of course I'm completely over it
um however right it's had me become
really interested in Beauty and so we
did these other studies where we had
women come into the lab
and we prepped them for this right so we
gave them all these instructions and we
told them they either had to come into
the lab bringing everything they would
wear if they were going to go on a hot
date makeup hair tools uh or the apples
are women bringing are they bringing
like a [__] power drill or something
what have they got with them
uh curling irons straighteners
straighteners people I see it's
beautification Tools application tools
not DIY tools right no no
um so and we will like okay so if you've
got to hold out you need to date you can
leave them at our office for the morning
but we're like you have to bring these
things in you can't not bring them in if
you don't bring them in you can't do the
experiment so they either had to come in
bringing all the hot date stuff or they
had to come in bringing
spending time at home with mates
stuff right
um and then they came into the lab and
we gave them half an hour or 20 minutes
to get ready in preparation for the hot
date or the hanging out with friends we
gave them a cubicle and it was all
locked and a mirror full-length mirror
we also gave them additional makeup
should they not have had a lot of money
for makeup but secretly super wanted red
lipstick we gave them stuff we said you
didn't have to use it it's just there in
case you would do it but we emphasized
you've got to do what you would actually
do for a hot date don't do what you
think we want you to do do what you
would do
then they came out of the uh came out of
that room and we did these experimental
tests on them to see whether they were
uh feeling more assertive after doing
that so we did
um what's called a kind of self-report
test where we just asked them explicit
questions on a computer monitor it's all
done privately but we might ask them
um
how much get up and go they feel like
they have how assertive they feel they
are How uh
you know how interested they would be in
promoting themselves that kind of thing
but then we also do these implicit tests
and these are computerized tests that
look to the participant like they're
measuring word associations and reaction
times so it literally looks like you're
staring at a computer screen words flash
up on a screen and you have to press a
button to categorize that word into its
most relevant category
um and we had categories related to
assertiveness right an agency which is
this assertiveness related concept and
in height so high assertiveness and low
assertiveness and then they these words
flash up on the screen like go together
and you'd put go-getter in the
assertiveness category and then other
words flash up on the screen like lazy
and you'd categorize lazy into the
non-assertiveness category
um and all that's well and good that's
really just to train people that they
know what the task does but then we have
their name flash up on the screen
and we have the word may flash up on the
screen and they have to do this in Split
seconds and they have to go oh and they
have to categorize their name as high
assertiveness or low assertiveness and
we do this hundreds of times to make the
test you know statistically valid
and then we're able to use that as this
other indicator of assertiveness you
know that on the implicit level and
these implicit tests are good because a
lot of research has shown you can't fake
them right you can't tell people what
they want to hear you just have to react
kind of intuitively
um and after running this study we found
that women who were in The Hot Date
condition who'd had to put on the
clothes and put on the makeup and do
whatever they were doing for a hot day
uh felt more assertive they rated
themselves as more assertive they were
implicitly more assertive
um and that was this other indicator
that this kind of strategic Beauty
strategy can leave women feeling more
assertive as well
when it comes to thinking about all of
this one of the things that you haven't
you mentioned earlier on about the sex
ratio
um have you looked at the proliferation
of beautification and sexy selfies in
connection with what the local ecology
sex ratio is
yeah we did look at it in terms of sex
ratio and we've looked at this
um twice so
the first time we looked at it alongside
that sexy selfie study and we didn't
find an effect there so it didn't seem
to matter what the sex ratio was whether
they were more men in the environment or
War women in the environment
um just reliably there was there was
just not it just didn't matter
um and then we we also did an
experimental study where we had
participants
um
do an online experiment where we primed
them for different sex ratios
um and how we did that is we
I think this was people in the US signed
up to do the study we found out where
they lived we they gave us their County
right and then we
um use that information to
uh automatically create an infographic
like a mini poster right kind of the
sort that you would see your government
produce about
maybe how much men in compared to women
and why we should readdress gender
inequality we have this poster and the
poster talked about the number of men
versus women in their environment and
um we did kitchy things like talk about
the number of fish in the sea and then
we wrote uh fake news articles where can
people were complaining about there
being a man drought or a woman drought
and we gave fake statistics about
they're being five only five uh
you know five men available for every
one woman or the opposite way around
basically we did all these different
manipulations to give people the
impression that their environment was a
good dating environment right lots of
opportunity or a poor dating environment
lots of competition
and then we measured women's interest in
uh
physical appearance and using physical
appearance to get ahead and we found no
effect there either wow I would not have
predicted that given yeah all of the
stuff that sex ratio hypothesis would
predict things to do with short-term
mating fewer dates before sex more in
all of that stuff
um I don't know why that wouldn't cross
over into the digital realm I'm gonna
guess that that's why you probably had
another crack at it to see if there was
something in there because it makes so
much sense before you actually get into
the data
yeah well we we thought the same thing I
was really surprised
um and the more I thought about it
though and the more I looked into it I
came up with some potential reasons why
we may not have found that effect
um one of them is that the sex ratio
literature mainly looks at sex ratio at
a population level it's very rare that
it's experimentally manipulated right so
usually what you do is you actually take
the real sex ratio in a place and then
look at real outcomes in a place
um and that's willing good and that has
some strengths but it leaves open that
kind of correlational analysis leaves
open the possibility that there is some
other predictor that is not being
measured that could account for that
finding
um an experimental test is really the
kind of strongest test you can do of
many of trying to find the relationship
between something and and very few
Studies have ex have looked at sex ratio
experiments so that was one thing
but then the other thing is you know
these sex ratio effects tend to be
stronger amongst men than they do
amongst women
um and what I mean by that is the sex
ratio tends to affect male Behavior more
than it does for your behavior and I
wonder if that's I think that may have
to do with this
biological trade-off between quality and
quantity
right so when people are interested in
well not really when people are
interested because these kind of
motivations happen in the background but
you know the motivation to
um to mate right for a male is is
benefited by in a lot of ways by
quantity right there's no kind of cap
for male reproductive success so in one
framework you know from one point of
view is a male is able to go and just
kind of sleep with as many women as
possible Right some of them are going to
get pregnant
um and if if he sleeps with 100 women
multiple of those women get pregnant
that's going to be a more of a benefit
to his reproductive success than finding
one super awesome really high quality
woman and uh just sleeping with her and
I'm talking purely numbers right
obviously there's a lot more complex
things going on I'm not saying all men
do that or that they should do that but
from a numbers perspective that's what's
going to benefit male reproductive
success
from the female perspective it's very
different
um having sex with multiple men is not
going to increase your reproductive
success necessarily you're limited by
the costs of pregnancy lactation you you
know that's that's that can take 9 10 11
12 two years right so quantity is not
necessarily the important thing there
the important thing is quality
um so the operational sex ratio that is
an indication of quantity right the
number of men or the number of women you
have available and I I think that we may
find these lesser effects amongst women
because that quantity distinction is is
just not so relevant that's interesting
that's my thought anyway yeah would it
not be the case that in an area that has
more men there is a greater chance of
you finding a higher quality man let's
say that there are 10 men out of every
100 that you would be prepared to get
into a relationship with but now there's
a thousand men oh well now there's a
hundred men that I would be prepared to
get into a relationship with I have no
idea how that would affect Behavior I
can see why given that men are playing
in numbers game and women are playing a
quality game a manipulation of the
numbers in the local ecology in terms of
sex ratio would result in men adjusting
their behavior more than women but
fundamentally the pool of quality men is
in impacted by the volume of man also
and given that women are more picky
maybe that compensates in some sort of a
way as well it's
it is very very interesting one of my
other favorite things that I saw you
look at was social inequalities
affecting conflict between the Sexes and
this is something that I've been pretty
obsessed with this sort of mating crisis
that's occurring at the moment the
difficulties that
um poorer men and richer women are
having what did you find in these models
yeah so this was I think what you're
talking about is the simulation study um
that we ran so this was a study that I
did with my collaborators Rob Brooks and
woods fromage
um and Lutz is a excellent modeler
um and he one of the things that he does
is run these simulation studies so
for those who are unfamiliar with it a
simulation study is purely uh kind of a
mathematical
um hypothetical right so what you do is
you put people in that you
they're not they're not people right so
you you
mathematically create actors in a
hypothetical environment and then you
can assign those actors a particular
property right like wealth
and then you can assign the environment
a particular property
um and in this case we assigned those
actors incomes so wealth right and then
we manipulated it to create inequality
in that environment both in terms of
income inequality just generally some
people really rich some people are
really poor some actors and then gender
inequality so actors that we assign to
be female less than actors we assigned
to be male or vice versa and we
manipulated that across a number of
different dimensions so you have a lot
of in a lot of in income inequality just
a little bit of income inequality a lot
of gender inequality or maybe you've got
perfect gender equality or even the
reverse where you see women earn more
than men so we played around with all
these different metrics
um and then what you do in that
simulation is you basically kind of
press go and iteratively over uh I think
we did a hundred simulation I think we
had a million in individuals and 100
simulations
you can measure a particular behavior in
that environment and see how those
metrics affect that behavior so we were
interested in pairing success
which we we kind of just
and we're interested in pairing success
under hypogony right so hypogony is this
general rule that you see across pretty
much all human societies where women
tend to marry up you call it hypergamy
but other people call it hypergamy
what's the difference between those two
yeah so that kind of used
interchangeably
hypergyne is is women you know Guinea
women marrying up hypogamy is or sorry
hypogyny is just women kind of pairing
up Gammy more has to do with marrying up
so they kind of they kind of mean the
same thing that people talk about them
in different contexts okay yeah
um so we use this simulation model to
try and understand
what was the success of pairing for male
actors versus female actors in this
environment depending on what they
earned and what other people earned
um and the it was a complicated paper
but there was some really key to two
takeaway points one takeaway point is
there are consistently these groups in
in society uh that are disadvantaged in
terms of pairing success
and um it doesn't matter if individuals
in these groups are lovely kind
individuals uh parent success will be
harder for them based on the economy in
society and those two groups of people
the first is poorer men
probably no surprises there and we can
talk about that but the second is rich
women
and that one usually people do find
quite surprising
um and what we see is that
those two groups do quite badly at
pairing when there is
any form of gender equality right those
two those two groups do worse when there
is gender inequality so if you kind of
think how the status quo used to be
those two groups do better and when
there is income inequality those two
groups especially men do even worse than
they were going to do before
hmm
so I understand the first two I
understand why in an environment that
has relative gender equality if women
are women women on average run to date a
man that's as rich or richer than they
are if there is an Ever decreasing pool
of men that are across and above from
them they've got the tall girl problem
right there are fewer and fewer men that
they can date exactly I understand how
the reverse of that would mean that men
even poor men are doing better than
women because some of those women on
average are just generally poorer
overall so it gives men a a a stepping
stone it gives them a raise up which
makes it easier for poor men to be that
hypergamous sort of above and across
male to women even if it's lower down
women the income inequality thing I
don't understand at all and I need you
to explain yeah so
it's kind of like what we're talking
about with those sexy selfies right and
in those economically unequal
environments people can see the benefits
of perhaps delaying pairing Now by
waiting to pair with an individual of
higher status later
um and what that means is you've got uh
this kind of incentive operating in that
Marketplace that is
when mating is hypergonas uh
is just making things worse
so I mean this is the
the fundamental quandary that I've been
playing around with for the last
year and a half or so
um given the fact at the moment that the
trends suggest two women for every one
man completing a four-year us college
degree by 2030 uh men are dropping out
of the U.S labor force at 0.1 percent
per month since the 1950s and it's going
to dip to 65 labor force participation
by 2050 50.1 percent of women childless
by 30 45 of 22 to 44 year old Prime
working age women will be single by 2040
according to I think it was right as or
somebody like that
um
what do you as a woman who is successful
and has a PHD and all the rest of it
what do you see
in the future as a potentially useful
way to frame this not whether it be
a conversation with the public or
potential policy implications or just
like cultural interventions and
Technologies like mimetic interventions
that we can do to try and make this
easier because it it sucks for women
that given the fact they've only just
reached educational and employment
parity that they're now basically facing
a a world where for every pound extra
that they earn their dating prospects
get worse and for every degree that they
get they're finding it harder to get
married and also men being forgotten and
flown and retreating into porn and video
games that rates greater than ever
before that if one sex loses both sexes
lose right and as far as I can see
sexlessness is increasing amongst men
I'm sure you've seen the stats about
tripled since 2008 to 2018 blah blah
it's not good for anybody at the moment
right
and yet saying women have you considered
being a little bit less educated or
economically independent it'll make your
dating Prospect better not a campaign
that is going to be particularly
successful for any politician to run on
right you must have considered you must
have considered this current sort of
cultural challenge that we Face given
the the ground truth of hypergamy so
what do you think
yeah so I think I I tend to be a little
less worried about the future in all
honesty I don't doubt those statistics
that you've said but I think that um
you know my understanding of the way
that these Dynamics play out is it's
always an arms race right so each sex is
kind of competing to do the best that
they can in the environment that they
are in and we're very plastic you know
we're very phenotypically plastic we
respond we we alter our Behavior to suit
our environment we adapt
um and
there are some big questions about how
fast we adapt but I think in in a lot of
these kinds of uh the in in this
particular discussion I think that
people are just going to find a way you
know that that pressure to
uh that pressure to mate is such a
strong one I think people are going to
find a way to do it now
um
my
you know what I've often said to women
when I talk to women in this position
and it usually tends to be women who are
a little more educated who are then
shocked that they're at a disadvantage
right they just they're like well that
was my experience but everybody just
told me that I was making things up or
that I was just not seeing the people
that are available and I'm like well no
you are statistically at a disadvantage
so
the the one thing that I think hypogony
May relax to some extent and it tends to
have done so in terms of education so um
what you are finding is that as women
are getting more educated their
preferences for men who are more
educated than themselves have started to
relax
the income one is still a strong one
um but it's hard to
test the strengths for that whilst we
still have gender inequality and income
right because whilst there is gender
inequality and income there is always
going to be an incentive if you're a
woman to pair with a man who is richer
than you that incentive will always
exist so I think that we're going to
continue to see that degree of hypogony
in in terms of income continue
now for
men in particularly for these these poor
men who are in this worse prospect it's
a really tough one right I I
making that kind of argument of well we
should try and have women be less
educated is just not going to work right
and particularly doing it in a way that
you seem resentful and aggressive and
and anti-woman is not going to appeal to
any women that you might want to attract
but at the same time to then ignore this
group of men and say oh well you should
just toughen up or and don't complain
about it is absolutely the wrong thing
to do
um and one of the things that we have
kind of advocated for and tried to speak
about is that we need to find a way to
support these young men without just
telling them that what they're seeing in
the market is inaccurate
um or that because men in general tend
to receive lots of benefits that their
gripes and their issues are something
that we should ignore
how we do that in reality is a tricky
question
one this is a bit of an indirect
approach is one is you know income
inequality is something we consistently
come back to being a problem one is we
could try and challenge income
inequality I authentically think that
would make a really big difference
um particularly amongst men's
competition with other men and that
would help these these worse off
individuals
um another indirect kind of pathway is
you know maybe we
work with those men to give them
something else that they can offer to a
romantic relationship that's not as
important as income maybe we train them
in being excellent parents I mean I know
that seems like a bit of an odd thing to
say but you know if women are looking
for at a population level uh taking care
of their resources right and then
wanting to be able to pair with someone
who can be a good parent if these men
are really finding it difficult to
handle that resource issue because
they're disadvantaged in particular ways
or maybe they just don't have interests
to go and be a stock broker they just
want to do something else which is
completely legitimate maybe we find them
a way that they can advertise their
prowess as parents you know and we can
invest in that way I mean these are some
potential things absolutely I mean I've
played with a bunch of these Solutions
so I'm trying to come up with them
pedestalizing motherhood and fatherhood
is definitely one of them because it
acts it steps outside of this existing
sort of hypergamous relationship and
takes us into this sort of more familial
thing a familial setting in which
characteristics like uh kindness
attentiveness humor Goodwill grit
determination conscientiousness that's
not being driven toward a capitalist and
all of those are able to come out right
in a really good in a really good way
however it it is currently very low
status to be a stay-at-home dad I mean
it's not exactly personalized to be a
stay-at-home mum but it's definitely not
pedestalized to be a stay-at-home dad so
so I I think that that may be a little
bit of an uphill battle although it's
not something that I would
um be like too averse to sing totally
right trying to claw back women's
recently achieved parity and education
employment is not even going to begin
getting anywhere
um raising up men I I I really don't
know what that means although I would
love to do it I speak to guys everybody
that's listening to this podcast that is
a guy is already outside of that bucket
of people they've already they're super
agentic they've got sovereignty they're
trying to improve themselves they can
consume it 45 minutes into a
conversation about very complex gender
Dynamics right like that they know what
they're doing it's the group that aren't
and oddly that's the strange thing that
the people that would benefit most from
listening to podcasts like this one are
the people that aren't listening to it
which is a little bit unfortunate
um one of the things that I am I don't
know
whether it's hopeful or not for is
trying to
encourage
both men and women to not see each other
as adversaries anymore I think that
trying to have a collaborative uh
conversation between the two Sexes would
make things a lot easier
um I think that
another start which I picked up last
year from Seth Stevens dividowitz's book
don't trust your gut is
a man who works in hospitality and earns
three hundred thousand dollars a year is
the same level of attractiveness As A
Firefighter or a lawyer that earns sixty
thousand dollars a year so basically
there is a two hundred and forty
thousand dollar disparity because
status especially from employment can be
conveyed in more ways than just your
monetary contribution now the problem is
in relationships where the woman is the
primary Breadwinner that twice as are 50
more likely to end in divorce and if the
woman contributes more than 80 percent
of the household income they're twice as
likely to end in divorce women are
roughly three times more likely than men
to say that they would value the
resource acquisition of their partner
because men just don't care about that
from a partner however women do so I
don't know one thing that Seth didn't
look at is
yes men are able to switch job titles
and become more attractive without
having to earn necessarily any more
money but he didn't work out what
happens if your wife earns 100 Grand and
you go from 300 to 60 I think that
Crossing that that income threshold is
actually going to be kind of like a a
flaw a hard floor that if you fall
through you're going to start to see
some weird externalities no matter how
sexy you look in your firefighters
outfit so I absolutely agree with you on
that one it's an interesting one you
know another thing that I I
think that we need to pay attention to
is
um
the
the ramifications that these mating
market conditions can have at a societal
level as well right so we need to be
let's take the the poor men situation
right so we need to be aware of the
situation for those individuals right
what it is like for those individuals
faced in that kind of Market we need to
be aware of things like
um
you know amongst the in-cell population
for example who are often associated
with this group of well who are
self-proclaimed disadvantaged in The
Mating Market one of the things we see
in that particular subpopulation is huge
rates of mental health problems right
huge rates of new neurodivergence autism
depression anxiety that are you know
double the rates even more just to the
usual population just to put it out
there we're not suggesting that not
having sex causes you to be autistic
we're suggesting that a lot of people
that are autistic and neurodivergent
tend to be in cells yeah yes that's
right yeah
um so
you know we need to be sensitive and
aware of those kinds of barriers as well
and I think it can be easy to just go
well it's sex whatever like we should be
focusing on people's uh on other
fundamental life motivations but for
many many people sex is very very very
important to them and not just very
important at ahead of your stick I like
getting my rocks off kind of way
important in terms of uh who I value
myself to be myself my self-worth my my
you know my one of the things that
motivates me to be living and feel like
I am really especially as a man my
masculine validity yes right and I I
think for far too long now we have just
ignored that as something that is
deserving of time and attention
um but so that would be the first thing
is the importance of what it's like for
those individuals the other thing is the
massive ramifications that it can have
for International Security when you
start to mess with mating market
dynamics right and uh what that can
cause for the prevalence of War what
that can cause for the prevalence of
increased violence theft property crimes
in general
um and
if Valerie Hudson who is a political
scientist in at Texas A M has done a lot
of work on this and so has Rose
McDermott who's over at Brown and they
have shown that these mating Market
obstructions where it's very hard for
young women young men to marry
um particularly in areas that are
polygenous right so that one man has
many wives and what that does is favor
rich men who can afford many wives it
means that
um
I I think in Afghanistan right now the
rate of buying a wife because it's a
It's that kind of broad price
environment you have to buy a wife the
rate of buying a wife is so expensive
that um only one son in each family
unless they're very ritual ever be able
to afford it and all of the other sons
and these are environments which favor
Sons so people tend to have more Sons
and Daughters all of the other Sons will
never marry they just have to work to
make sure that the Elder son can marry I
mean imagine being one of those guys
right you're never going to find a wife
you're never going to earn enough money
to find a wife your elder brother if you
give him all your money will find a wife
but uh and and that's what your family
culture has to do now then imagine a
group like the Taliban comes along and
I'm simplifying a little but not that
much a group like the Taliban comes
along and says we need to get women out
of Education
we need to I'll give you money it will
be religiously righteous and we're going
to get women out of education and we're
going to give you a wife if you join our
Insurgency and join our course
and all of a sudden in these
environments you have these men
presented with completely black mating
Market prospects and then presented with
a group that tells them we'll get bills
out of Education which for these
uneducated men is a no-brainer why would
you want girls being uneducated if
you're an uneducated man and and you
know that educated women won't be
interested in you then they tell you
we'll give you a job and we'll give you
money right okay well that's a
no-brainer and you know part of these
Dynamics is they're fueling these very
very problematic uh International
Security dilemmas to do with Warfare to
do with terrorism to do with violence
and then we kind of we ignore that
structural consequence as well
wasn't there something in medieval
Portugal
where the first son there was so few
women sex ratio was was split in a
particular way that the first one was
the only one that could get a wife or
maybe maybe it was a gerontocracy or
maybe there was some Barons that had
captured all of the hot young women or
something and they just shipped all of
the other younger Sons first son
fantastic you're laughing you get family
and wife all of the other Sons what they
did in order to um
be a pressure release valve for this
latent sexual frustration was they sent
them off on Galleon ships and they said
go explore the new world you can go be
pirates of the sea you can go do all of
this stuff so they literally exported
every man that wasn't the first son in a
desperate attempt to try and tune down
this young male syndrome so okay we've
spoken about what's happening in
countries where the no matter what you
think about the West the gender
inequality is worse right it is it's not
as bad over here as it is over there
yeah
do you think that the West has an
in-cell problem in terms of societal
stability and security
I don't I don't
I'm giving you my intuition on this
because there's very poor quality data
on it but my intuition on it is that um
what we're talking to what we're calling
in cells in the west is prevalent in all
different environments we just may not
use that term and in those environments
they may not be vocal on English social
media and use hashtags to do within
cells but that underlying sentiment of
disgruntled aggrieved young men who have
poor prospects of finding a date and the
likelihood of those men engaging in kind
of societal disruption I think is
evident everywhere okay so I have a
theory this is the first time I've
actually it's the first time I've been
able to talk about it since I put a name
to it and it wasn't me that put a name
to it it was uh Vincent Harem and
William Costello uh it's Williamson's
sedation hypothesis so
um
I noticed in one of your papers that you
said
physical violence is rare a rare but
growing problem between 2014 2018
reactionary in cells killed 50 people
across North America and Europe so
that's
50 people too many shouldn't have
happened one of them in 2020 or 2021
happened on the south coast of England
um almost all of the killings that you
do see when it comes to mass shootings
that occur in schools when it comes to
Jihadi uh terrorists that come over
they're almost all you know categorized
as in cells however given the
here to unforeseen and unknown levels of
sexlessness amongst young men
we definitely should have presumed that
we would have had tons and tons more
insult killings where are all of the
killings at is a question that I've been
asking myself and it is my current Bro
Science belief that men are being
sedated out of their status seeking and
sexual frustration Behavior with porn
and video games so this is Diana
fleischmann's uncanny evolvers theory
that she's got about porn and you can
see easily enough what happens with
video games it's a ton I saw some data
the other week that said
um nearly a third of unemployed men who
are between the ages of 18 and 30 are
spending their time spending over 2 000
hours per year playing uh video games
and of that group there is a huge number
that are on either prescription or
recreational drugs while they do it and
my point being that
if it's true that young male syndrome in
2023 is happening in the same way as it
would have done in previously unstable
societies where the Stax ratio or the
mating Market gets messed up all of
these young men why are they not running
around graffitiing stuff and pushing
over granny like where are they all this
isn't a call to arms for them to start
doing stuff it is good yep it is me
saying it's simply not there the stats
straight up are not that you could have
yeah it could be like it could have been
diluted down by one tenth and you would
have still seen a significant increase
2008 to 2018 eight percent to 28 of men
having no sex in the last year between
the ages of 18 and 30 which is that age
that would cause this trouble and that
finishes in 2018 roll covered on top of
that role pathogen risk and increased
levels of disgust and blah blah blah
social anxiety all of this I honestly
think it could be over 50 percent of men
walking down the street maybe 40 if you
pointed a man on the street a one in two
chance that if he's between the ages of
18 to 30 hasn't had sex in the last year
that is such a huge increase in the
state of less than two decades
there should be more of these troubles
and there isn't and it seems that porn
use and video game use are the two
easiest outlets for that camaraderie
status seeking vasopressin dopamine
behavior and they're getting some it's
not quite reproductive Fitness signals
but it's good enough it's a you know a
titrated dose
Williamson's sedation hypothesis
I I I think the sedation word is just
such a beautiful term in this one right
and it actually reminds me of some web
that I did with this uh so I've done a
little bit of work with an evolutionary
biologist Mike casumovich and he has
looked at violent video games and how
they relate to make value and whether
playing violent video games can give you
this kind of boost of making making make
you feel like you're more of a dude
right like you're more of a man you've
got higher mate value and he actually
does find effects consistent with that
but then he also finds these things
where if you lose a game particularly if
you lose a video game to a woman and
you're a guy you are super unhappy about
it you're like more aggressive you're
more of a jerk but if you lose to a man
it's not so bad
um and he does a lot of his work on um
or a lot of his initial work was
actually on spiders and on phenotypic
phenotypic plasticity in spiders and
mating Dynamics and spiders but he's a
super interesting guy now he does some
human stuff and he talks about that
people are playing violent video games
to practice dominance right because
they're having trouble with dominance in
the offline world so maybe they use the
online world to practice dominance
and I think that aligns nicely with your
kind of hypothesis
I I also think that would be simplistic
to assume that the and I know that
you're not doing this but it would be
simplistic to for people to think that
the only Outlet then from that kind of
mating disadvantage is societal
disruption so one of the things that has
happened over time and over development
is we've kind of our brains have
developed we've found other ways to try
and resolve the issues that we face and
try and channel those those kinds of
problems into other ways so I think that
there is
that ability as well how you would go
about doing that other than
you know potentially just complaining to
you Mates is a really problematic
question right I've looked at uh
correlations between local
sex ratios in the state of the local
mating market and in selectivity online
misogynistic tweets and then that
Downstream related into domestic
violence or domestic abuse and stuff
like that too right yeah yeah yeah and
we um so we do find this correlation
between offline and online behaviors
there so one of the things we found was
that again you know consistent theme
income inequality in crisis the
likelihood of in-cell ideology
um it makes it more prevalent
um and we also find that when when the
advantage that men hold over women in
terms of how much they earn so that kind
of gender inequality effect when that
Gap erodes so when men and women's
earnings become closer and closer
there's more in cell ideology there as
well
um
and then in relation to the offline
world one of the things we tracked was
the kinds of misogynistic discourse that
a lot of in cells engage in and we
related that to domestic and Family
Violence outcomes and we find that there
is this predictive relationship where
when an air when the social media
chatter in a particular region
um becomes more misogynistic what you
find is that you start to see more
domestic and family violence in that
area and you even see this predictive
effect as well where if misogyny
increases one year right next year
you'll see more domestic and Family
Violence there as well and that's just a
small effect but these lag effects kind
of suggest that one of the things that
societies could do this is a this is a
potential policy area one of the one of
the things that we could do at a
societal level is start to also track
sentiment on social media to try and
understand and predict where offline
behavior is going to change later right
we could track misogyny we could start
to track these this Intel ideal that you
we could track people's resentment and
disgruntlement about the Sexes and use
that information to then look at some of
these more pernicious crimes and and you
know the outcome of those crimes later
on and potentially then
divert resources into those areas to try
and rectify ahead of time almost it's
like being able to see the future so
Seth the guy that wrote Don't Trust
you're good during covert during the
first wave of covid he was able using
aggregated Google search data
he was able to predict where outbreaks
were going to occur
three to five days before they did with
greater accuracy than the CDC and what
he was doing was he was using searches
for things like
um why can't I smell why is my
temperature going all over the case why
can't I taste my food he had a bunch of
different search criteria and sure
enough it mapped on perfectly so I'm all
down for some whatever what was that
thing where uh Tom Cruise was able to
see the future what was that Minority
Report Minority Report don't want don't
want people arrested before it happens
but you can prepare
um you know compensatory facilities to
maybe help people with stuff if you
could see things like that
um I was talking yeah I was talking to
William Costello before we came on and
he has got some stuff from the paper
that hasn't even been released yet that
I thought I would tell you about you
said I'm allowed yeah great um in cells
have a lower minimum mate preference
than non-in cells so this disproves the
incels just have two high standards idea
that in cells have even lower standards
than men of their say mate value that
are not self-identified as in cells so
they lower their standards to try and
compensate and the other one which is
really interesting in cells and non-in
cells overestimate the importance that
women say they place on financial
resources and physical attractiveness
but underestimate kindness intelligence
and humor so this is what women say so
it's stated not revealed preferences and
the unfalsifiability of some areas of
the incel ideology might say well you
know I know what women like more than
women do and you go well I don't know
maybe but at least in this regard they
overestimated the importance that women
said that they uh placed on it which
becomes a little bit of a self-defeating
situation especially if you're a man
that is in that poor cohort
yeah it does and I think it links to
that real nihilistic view that some in
cells have that they're never going to
find any that black people ideology of
no matter what I do I'm never going to
be able to find a mate I I've always
found it really
um perplexing and what you've shared
there kind of makes sense of that is and
is consistent with this I've always
found it really perplexing that there's
this aspect of in-cell behavior that is
so preoccupied with how men look right
LMS Lux money space looks maxing right
right and looks maxing right so it's all
about looks and
the irony is
you know when you look at the
evolutionary psychology literature
um women don't care as much about looks
as they do about status
and
this is what's made me kind of start to
think about
it links back to women's use of beauty
right as well I have this I I have this
kind of intuition that
for both sexes that what you're doing is
trying to gain status in any way that
you can right and different people have
different opportunities available to
them some people have Rich fancy
educations they can get and they can
Flash and other people can have fancy
cars and or some people can gain The
Prestige within their social networks
and be very important amongst that
social network
but other people don't have those kinds
of options available but what they do
have available to them is potentially
working on their body
and I think that amongst both sexes what
you may find is that in environments
where people don't feel they have many
status opportunities available to them
they look at one of the things that they
could use to gain status and then they
focus on their body and that that might
be why you see so much of that amongst
incel men as well did you see I don't
know whether you follow William but if
you don't you absolutely need to I do
this was a tweet
that he put up
last week this is from scipost
heterosexual women prefer men who are
taller and have broader shoulders and
consider them more masculine and have
better fighting ability larger upper
bodies boost attractiveness ratings for
taller men they don't appear to have the
same effect for shorter men
uh where is it here according to this
study it didn't have the same effect in
improving attractiveness as it did for
tall men however I think slight
muscularity compared to Fat flab scrawny
will give even short men a better chance
I'll tell myself this as I do curls in
the mirror William is a a short King so
he uh I think he had a
personal investment there however yeah
yeah I I don't get it wrong we were
talking about this as we were walking
around
um me and my housemate were walking
around the park the other day discussing
the fact that
is it easier for men or women to change
their make value
was the question in this modern mating
world that we've got
um and I think I came up with the idea
that I think uh men are more screwed as
a group but have it better individually
and women are more screwed individually
but have it better as a group at the
moment I think that um any one man who
manages to ramp up their
conscientiousness and their motivation
for a little bit of time can easily add
you know any average man can easily add
sort of two points onto probably the out
of 10 make value especially if they
haven't cared about it before a little
bit of work on yourself in the gym some
good new clothes work on career for a
couple of years time you know you've
started to gain a little bit more income
that's relatively easy I think that shy
of cosmetic surgery which has some
resource limitations on it for women you
are kind of bouncing on off and upper
bound and you are permanently from the
age of 21 permanently on a downhill
slope away from your Peak sexual market
value for most men right this isn't to
say that some women don't like Bloom and
still look great into their 40s and
stuff but you know what I mean
um
but my point being when it comes to as a
group
I don't know how we uh fix this 19
percentage point or 15 percentage Point
difference between men and women at
universities at the moment
um where you've got Title IX was brought
in
sorry title name was brought in when
women were 15 percentage points behind
men and it's now 19 percentage points in
the other direction uh and I I don't
know how you fix that I don't know how
you fix the sort of uh labor force
dropouts and stuff for men women I think
it is harder for them individually to
change their make value I think that
there are just fewer routes that are
open to them however if you look as a
group I think women overall have at
least a little bit of a brighter future
in the uh
both groups are going to be alone for a
little while on average both groups are
going to be increasingly alone but at
least women can be rich and educated
while they're alone
um so that that was my that was what
you're thinking from yeah yeah I don't
know look I think both both sectors have
challenges and I I don't know if I would
say that it would kind of be easier or
harder for each sex like my devil's
advocate view would kind of go yeah but
as a woman you could still be an
absolute jerk and you could just find a
great lipstick and you know a dress that
was particularly satisfying and some of
that kind of slimming underwear and
you've got a better shot there and fix
it thanks right thanks and as a as a guy
it's going to take a long time to try
and earn that kind of big bucks in in
that economically unequal environment
like sure kindness always helps
um so I don't know I think both sexes
have got disadvantages that we're
playing with and both sexes have
advantages and one of the things that
you mentioned
earlier was you know you think it would
be helpful if people would stop being so
antagonistic right and you know both
sexes have to stop doing the other sex
as a problem and I 100 agree with that
and one of the things that I think is
actually the access to that is
having
and I don't mean this prescriptively
like people should just go out and do
this so that would be good is having a
decent understanding of how this kind of
evolutionary arms race stuff works right
at the most basic level
everybody is trying to do the best that
they can right everybody has strengths
and everybody can be a jerk both sexes
both women both men you know both men
and women we can all be absolute jerks
and we can all be great and we're both
doing the best with every with what
we've got and I
I don't know this might be my I might be
this might be my life coaching
background kind of getting in the way
there but I think the access to not uh
demonizing the other sex is
understanding that you can be a real
jerk as well
it's okay like it it's it if you can
kind of look yourself in the mirror and
know that you can be a total jerk and
that doesn't mean that you are a total
jerk right it just means that you can
have those qualities and you can also
let those qualities go and so can other
people I think that's a real access to
not making it the other sexist problem
it's very wrong very very yeah it's you
are this thing not you do this right not
you behave in a particular way it's you
are this it's like infused your spirit
you [__] unlovable harpies or you
like awful neck bearded in cells or
whatever it is right that's the way that
this gets framed and this is I mean this
is my current pet Obsession it's what
I'm writing about most mornings it's
um and also given that I'm coming
into this world of you know gender
Dynamics sex Market imbalance whatever
uh on YouTube which if you are talking
about this and you're a guy that looks
like me
you're spouting off about how women are
these sort of awful
coddled
pieces of [__] who have absolutely no
idea about what their make value is and
although there are some kernels of Truth
to like the fundamental basis it is
taken and blown up to such a degree that
I think it's actually a net negative to
this discussion because it makes people
both men and women think that they have
an understanding about what these
evolutionary precepts are and it's wrong
so not only do you no longer have the
learner's mind which is great for
keeping you open to new things you're
closed off to any new evidence because
you already have your ideology which has
come out of whatever corner of the
internet you believe is already right
but now you're still dealing with the
same problems and not prepared to make
any changes so yeah I think um tuning
down that adversarial relationship and I
see you know this isn't just the stuff
that comes from guys like R female
dating strategy
um the pernicious thing about the advice
for women is that it comes from more
mainstream uh uh Outlets magazines yeah
it's real [__] at least guys if guys
want to get [__] advice they've got to
go on the internet if girls want to get
[__] advice they just need to go to the
news agent because L and Cosmopolitan
will happily write articles teaching
women how to sleep with him and not
catch feelings
your article is teaching women how to
disembody themselves from letting
another person inside of them so that
they can what claim that that's Freedom
that doesn't sound particularly free to
me so that that is definitely for women
they have that much worse I think that
the
mainstream dating advice for women
and and Men is bad but men it's not
harmful men it's just useless like women
it's genuinely harmful
um yeah it makes it
stopping reading Cosmopolitan now and
stuff like that I think would make would
make the world a better place final
thing yeah you used to do gender studies
I did yeah how do you go
from doing gender studies to being an
evolutionary psychology scholar
yeah look for me it was a
um
I think for me so there's one thing I've
always been
open-minded right I'm a pretty
open-minded individual and I did gender
studies because I was really passionate
about gendered issues and was that Keen
on figuring them out
um and then I worked as a life coach and
business coach for a bit and then I
decided to start doing psych and I
didn't even know evolutionary psychology
existed when I started doing my
undergrad in Psych
um and
I started to you know in the first week
of my PhD I went to a summer school and
it was run by the Society of
australasian social psychologists and in
this summer school
um I sat in a workshop in an
evolutionary psychology and you know I'm
sitting there and I'm super excited to
be there and I'm listening to the
presenter start talking about sexual
conflict I'm like okay yeah this is
right down my alley I love this stuff
and then he started talking about the
evolutionary reasons of why we have such
common patriarchal backgrounds to so
many different cultures then he started
talking about make value and pressures
on appearance and I sat in this workshop
and I was flabbergasted right and after
being flabbergasted I then started to
feel really pissed off
and I was pissed off not because
there was this whole framework that in
biology to understand what I was so
committed by I was pissed off that I'd
spent an entire gender studies degree
looking at it and no one had told me
about it
I was like I was not doing gender
studies to be kind of pigeonholed into
only looking at one framework to try and
solve this issue I was committed to
trying to rectify sexual politics and
make a difference to sexual Harmony I
don't care what framework you throw at
me if the framework's going to make a
difference I want to hear about it and
it got me really rolled up and
um in in kind of presenting it that way
it makes it sound like I think that the
problems only in gender studies and that
only gender studies is closed to other
views and I don't think that um I think
that
both biological camps and socio-cultural
camps can be closed to alternate views
and my kind of
uh
flag in the ground from that point
onwards was that I was always going to
find a way to combine nature nurture
Frameworks that in the topics I cared
about you had to do both and I really
just made it my business to do both ever
since and it's I find it really
satisfying I mean it's challenging
because you kind of sit in this
Crossroads where you're kind of not
really part of either camp and you are a
little bit but then they always judge
whether you're really part of the camp
in the right ways but that crossroads
works for me you know I tend to be a
little more controversial I don't mind
sitting at the crossroads and and I
think
ultimately at a values level I really
authentically believe you've got to be
accounting for both biology and culture
and really if you truly understand
biology you know that culture is part of
the biology
um so yeah I sit in both worlds what do
you think most gender studies Scholars
misunderstand about human nature
I think that they
um
I think that they misunderstand how
plastic everything is
um and that and what I mean by that is
how responsive we are to what's going on
in the environment I think that they
believe that
um
culture can be separated from biology
and I think they believe that
I don't think they understand really
what an arms race is you know I mean I'm
sure they could Define it right but I
don't think they really understand how
that plays out and how
people are battling for uh doing well
and flourishing in the environment that
they're in and they're going to use the
tools available to them and and
from what I hear about
coming out of gender studies camps there
is a good bit of adversarial sort of
arms racy type language is that
misguided am I reading it wrong
um
look I I don't know if I would say you
were reading it wrong but I think that
the I I think that that my take of that
world is it can be kind of very wrapped
up in victims and persecutors you know
there's no
it's kind of one directional there's
either the there is the group that is
doing
bad things to the other group right and
then that group is there's oppressors
and depressed exactly yes thank you much
more eloquently said
um and and I so I think they get kind of
wrapped up in that narrative and then I
think there can be a tendency to ignore
the fact that an individual within a uh
oppressor group does not mean that they
are necessarily having a better life
situation right so
much more important than being in the
oppressor or the oppressed grouper in
let's say the male or the female group
much more important than which group
you're in is your position as an
individual I think that you know an
evolutionary biology has shown to us
that individuals do not act in the best
interests of their group they act in the
best interest of themselves
um and that is one of the kind of core
misconceptions and one of the insights
that I think would make the biggest
difference to these socio-cultural
explanations yeah I mean
the idea that because of your sex or
race or country of birth or whatever it
might be that you are inherently having
a better time like if if I had the
choice between being a middle class
black guy or a super working class white
guy like I know which one I'm going to
take and no one ever really wants to
talk about class especially coming from
the UK and people in America don't
really understand this I don't know what
Australia's class system or lack is
thereof is is like but the UK is still
so class-based I think it's because
we're just so old right it's inculcated
in the postcode that you live in in the
streets that you're on it's it's
everything and um
yeah coming from somewhere that is so
class
dominant
um there was a really good
article a really good um hiring drive by
a bank a couple of years ago that said
rather than it being we're going to
arbitrarily pick some like ethnic or sex
group and we're going to have this
amount of this many people they decided
that they were going to pick I think it
was 30 of 30 of managers by this
particular year were going to be from a
working-class background
uh and I thought that's a cool policy
because that cuts across the board right
doesn't discriminate based on race sex
anything it's like there we go anyway
Candice Blake ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do where should they go
uh follow me on Twitter I talk about the
work a lot there and the new papers
there a lot
um or going
to go outside at the Melbourne School of
psychological Sciences you can just
Google Evolution lab and you'll come
right across us done this I appreciate
you thank you thanks very much Chris
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]